obviously I got to do this before I go  away but I think that on reflection the  silly thing to do but just to let  everybody know I sort of helped out what  was a somebody I've known for thirty  years and unfortunately the never in  judgment on my behalf and I've heard the  consequences but you know entrapment is  one on this occasion and I have to  accept that and the agreement was done  very amicably with the FA apologized to  those and all concerned it was in those  on unfortunate situation I put myself in  so I have a confidentiality agreement  legs and there I took the time to talk  to you on this matter I can't answer any  more questions just now going to go away  and reflect on it I'm off abroad just to  chill out reflectin I'd like to wish all  the England lads Gareth and the staff  all the very best  was that your last job in football  though who knows who NC